i feel like uh last time we spoke you
guys were still you guys were you're
going hey check out our podcast check
out our podcast and now you have built
what is one of the most lucrative
empires
in all of podcasting the ru garbage
model is what they're calling it sure
right it's uh it's incredible where are
we at with these with these patreon
goals are we going to disney world what
i got i got to tell you stupid [ __ ] yeah
we're doing a lot of stupid yeah you
guys make mistakes you guys are like
elon is a billionaire and so he's just
gonna go ahead and take over twitter and
you guys are like podcast billionaires
so you're doing your own version build
the rocket ship at the studio
we're the epitome of new money so i got
he's never been to disney so one of the
goals was once we hit i forget however
many was
i'm going to take him to disney world
for the first time but it's raising a
bit of an issue because he can't fit on
any of the rides so it's a waste of like
seven grand
it's goddamn teacups are you guys going
with listeners are you just the two no
i'm just taking it
isn't that great that's what happens
when you go independent you're like you
know it would be a good bit we have the
listeners send us to disney world
[Laughter]
so that's what your kids
so that's right now that's what the
thing is it's like okay how do we
how do we make this worthwhile
yeah
i'll tell you i did uh
when
my wife was pregnant with our daughter
it was like uh you know she wasn't like
super super pregnant but she was like
five months pregnant probably mm-hmm and
so i was like you know you're doing the
roller coasters
that's news i didn't know
so
i go on the earth shaker she'll be all
right
i go you know what i'm gonna do she
loves disney i go this is the last time
we got the one kid it's a lot but it's
like this is the last time it's like for
her birthday and it's like three weeks
out which is not a lot of time to plant
disney no i was like i'm gonna surprise
her i'm gonna real quick plan a trip to
disney world i'm gonna get my mom to
take care of our baby i'm gonna do the
whole thing and like blah blah blah i
plan the trip i get a little wristband
we go to disney and she's like
you know i can't ride
anything any of the rides right and i'm
like you got the ears on in the big
lollipop yeah i'll see you on tuesday
i go here's the thing a big part of it
is the aesthetic like waiting in line to
get on the ride is a big part of the
experience so we'll just we'll go online
together what and then i'll ride the
ride that's insane it's horrible
i'll meet up with you right after and
when i don't get to the thing that i've
always had with disney like when i was a
kid we couldn't afford to go so all my
cousins we still can't really afford to
go but when my cousins went i would
always hate it be like [ __ ] dude
[Music]
you're you have one kid you're about to
have another why not wait a year and
take the kids
well we're gonna bri you can't wait a
year like you can't bring a w we can
bring a one-year-old to disneyland
yeah it's lost it's always
some would say
look
look you can't but she can go on the
kilimanjaro safari
they smell the french
these mountain lions won't stop
following us around are you guys
bringing a video a video crew when you
go yeah we got our producer uh our
producer t-bone who we take everywhere
he shoots everything uh
what a gig
yeah exactly so uh the next one we're
working on we're like i think we're like
a hundred or a couple patrons away
something like that just a bad one this
is we got all drunk one night at a
dinner and we were like what are we
gonna do and i was like because it's
like you now we're like painting
ourselves into a corner you gotta
somehow you gotta top disney you gotta
start topping all this [ __ ] i can't be
like oh we're gonna go to the shore
it crosses the jackass real quick
i'm taking a medicine ball in the
stomach
so we're gonna do one ten thousand
dollar roulette spin on black in
atlantic city which we wanted to talk to
you about
yes which we really can't afford
you got that on you or what
are you cash right now
we're gonna [ __ ] eight hookers one of
them has aids
[Laughter]
i do love that i feel like the listeners
would love it too like we got you to a
point where you have 10 grand in cash
and you can use the 10 grand and we get
to watch you lose it all in a second
well they're also they're also like
they're like because they know we're
we're idiots like we made some money
last year we didn't save any for taxes
like we're like we're still relatively
your paycheck so they're all like don't
do it man it's not worth it like save
your money pay the tax man and all that
stuff so they're looking out for us
they're like our you know they're like
our parents did you used to be a lawyer
or something no i used to work at a law
yeah firm so if you worked at a law firm
aren't you like isn't that kind of your
whole part of the thing like i'm going
to be the one who's smart enough to know
that we finally made some money we're
going to have to pay taxes yeah he's
also a dirt bike
philly he knows not to walk away from
the table when he's on a heater
i come from a long line of dirt bags and
cars being repossessed so it's like
we're not you know we're not the most uh
financially sound uh
clan and i put us in a pretty bad spot
this week uh we were at los angeles i
saw some pretty suspicious photos
i got us kicked out of a a five thousand
dollar airbnb with no refund
after 24 hours
i get a message you gotta go a legend by
the way a legend yeah this person in the
photo i was he was ripping a heater in
the driveway of a of a house in runyon
canyon which apparently is like forest
fire central
but this gentleman as i talked to him
did not know
so wait you guys rented a 5 000 airbnb
now is that for the week yeah yeah it
was for like a week for like five nights
we're or six nights we're like let's go
it's first time we're going to la we're
doing a run of shows we did san fran and
la and uh san diego were like let's go
out there and be comfortable and you
know and had a pool
live like you should be living live like
a couple of modern day success stories
pictures this is what the airbnb we
don't know who that is
there's a we'll tweet that out
in case any of you have seen i've seen
the perpetrator this mysterious person
yes it's a
fairly average looking human being dude
i go to task me and the airbnb guy who
was a real jerk off we're going i'm like
we have not smoked on the property i can
guarantee it meanwhile he's sitting next
to me this whole time knowingly he
smoked and i'm like dude we didn't break
any of the rules i'm a respectful guy
all this stuff and i just get that
message back and i just
he sent me the picture that's from the
ring camera oh there he goes then
explain this and i was like all right
we'll be out we'll be out by 9 a.m
nothing no
well i would i he might have given him a
break had there not been a huge argument
in which case one party was saying you
are lying sir there is no smoking oh
meanwhile he had a photo the entire time
he dude he played that like a [ __ ]
draw foreign [ __ ] uno he was like
take that [ __ ] you should have told him
that dolph sweet showed up
it's oddly enough he looks pretty it's
the roles or the filter but it's kind of
muscularis yeah i look like i fight
x-men
i'll go [ __ ] two rounds of wolverine
that's how you do you look strong right
yeah
i've been hitting the gym you know what
i'm saying have you yeah i'm trying to
build up a little muscle yeah now we can
lift heavier sandwiches
you should see him with a foot long so
you went there and you guys how many
days were you there
two i think that was the first night so
then the next day we got kicked out uh
and then we had to spend like [ __ ] 3
500 on a new place but i had a bigger
pool
coming up how did he tell you he was
booting he called you to go
i was going back and forth with him
right he was like hey you know i don't
remind you no smoking i'm like hey
listen we have and he was being real
pushy about all the rules so i took a
stand i'm like hey man we haven't been
you're being kind of ridiculous at this
point and you're you know like you're
just all up in my business we paid you
the money [ __ ] skedaddle you know and
then he drops that on me and then i was
holy [ __ ] i'm so sorry you know i'll
talk
obesity is a huge problem in america
right now especially los angeles
especially especially especially
millionaires
so he uh so then he turned me over to
airbnb support and that's when i
realized i was pretty jammed up
here they were like hey you know get
that guy off the property
uh you know that guy off the property
so it was just like a lot of back and
forth and i thought we were good
and then
he started sending more pictures of
guests who were guests he's like get
this unauthorized guest out of the out
of the off the property who was our
producer toby and i'm like you met him
yesterday
i know he looks like a dirtbag
so and then they were just like hey we
can't come to a resolution
you did break the rules of no smoking on
the property so he doesn't feel safe
with you in the house and you got no
money back no money back and i bet that
house didn't sit empty did it no dude so
i'm looking that night we're driving we
load up the car we hop in the car and
we're going to record a another podcast
and i'm like looking for places to stay
that night and the house is [ __ ]
already listed to rent that night oh he
just doubled i wanted to message him
like hey man i'm in town for a couple of
nights looking for a nice place to stay
that's how you turn five to ten real
quick yeah [ __ ] real dirtbag [ __ ]
move yeah so he turned five to ten and
you guys went in the other direction
what is it so eighty five hundred yeah
it was about a twenty thousand dollar
swing on the weekend yeah that's
where was that camera it's outside it's
that's on the garage yeah so it's like
that's looking down the driveway was he
watching you guys i think he gets off on
this one yeah like as soon as we got
there you got to take your shoes off and
this that and the other thing and the
first contact we had with him about
being a psycho was this before i don't
know if he had the picture in his back
pocket but the morning after that that
was taken the first night that we got
there the next morning we were at
breakfast and i hope you've made a
t-shirt out of that
that's going on lunch boxes that's
paying for disney
toby
we met up with toby and he told toby the
story and i could see toby getting
visibly angry and he's like yeah but
then he sent me this picture toby walks
away for a second and turns around and
goes lunch boxes thermos
school bags it's going everywhere
yeah you got to make your five grand
back on it
he's in the hole he's on a payment plan
already
but no so we uh
that happened the first night and then
the next morning at breakfast we were
going to have we recorded andrew santino
while we were out there uh on the coast
and we were gonna have him over but we
were worried with all these [ __ ]
rules that we read so kippy called him
it was like hey man just so you know
we're gonna have our cousin come by for
lunch he's like call me
you can't have any but you gotta yeah he
answers the phone he goes you didn't
read the rules i go hey i did read the
rules i just mentioned them in the
message that we that i sent you but
clearly i read them he was real l.a what
a pain in the surgery the [ __ ] fish
no i was like at 11 o'clock on like a
wednesday i'm like what kind of what
kind of trouble are we going to get into
then you know i like how jim said that
you could have a guest for london yeah
for i do
not [ __ ] airbnb
yeah we did airbnb because we were there
was four of us going out there i'm like
four of us in l.a for a week it's going
to be seven eight grand that i don't
want to spend and then i ended up
spending seven or eight grand yeah yeah
i'm sure they're good but i don't trust
people with hidden cameras dude
i panicked like that too and then you
know they ended up getting us that was
it i took that picture that was our
backyard it was [ __ ] sweet bro i love
i love
that that there's a before and after
dude
look at how excited you are this is
literally you're sitting there going
the world is ours i got a mimosa next to
me it was our only day off where that
was my room to the right right there if
he's that nervous why is he on airbnb i
think it's a scam like he was like i
throw people like when we got there and
checked in he's like i i don't mind
throwing people out i'm like i get it
you know whatever whatever maybe that's
the business like he just watches
waiting for you to break off he probably
doesn't have a family or anything like
he you know he just
[ __ ] because he made 10 grand instead
of five grand yeah he just ingratiates
himself into like these people's lives i
walked right into his trap yeah what are
some of the rules besides smoking and
not having shoes off as soon as you get
in the house but it's also like shoes
off if you're if you're wearing out your
shoes off a hundred dollar fine smoking
on the property thousand dollars
sleeping on the couch sleeping on the
couch thousand dollar fine what all this
[ __ ] for taking a nap i know but how
would they know they shouldn't know if
you slept on the couch they shouldn't be
watching you sleep i know it's weird so
i ultimately they also threatened to
kick me off airbnb about five times why
just because you know i broke the house
rules and
uh apparently we're just like a group of
animals that can't be taken anywhere i
think he thought you were the guy in
that picture there's no way he thought i
was the guy in that picture
he was probably confused
guy put on weight since i left did you
like la do you guys like it uh
in what sense i i mean i enjoy it it's
relaxing out there yeah beautiful the
weather's beautiful i like the layout
you know if i had a little bit of coin i
could see living in one of those
neighborhoods because you have a regular
neighborhood you know what i mean with
like nice houses but then you walk half
a block you're at a 7-eleven you got
your taquitos in the whole nine years
yeah that's true
yeah ma'am yeah well uh uh i did [ __ ] up
one more time though in la if you want
to know oh yeah so yeah that's our
position i wish it was in the chateau
marmonton
that's why you were spiking up
the continental breakfast killed me
i don't know what they put in those eggs
over there
were they fentanyl
no just eggs just a lot of them
fully caught a hot batch of what french
toast
uh he gets all [ __ ] up that we were
you know we're at that ye old rustic ale
house or whatever uh he gets he goes i'm
going home we go okay great yeah
this you know [ __ ]
bozo goes home deadbolts the lock to the
airbnb and it's just like a keypad so he
deadbolts it from the inside
passes out plus his headphones to myself
phone's dead
passes out puts headphones in closes the
door and is just [ __ ] out i have my
cpap ball on him
he's gone dude
so at like one o'clock we start trying
to get in the house we can't get in and
we're trying we're banging on the door
where there's like two or three of us
just banging on the door and all you're
hearing is
yeah he's like a fighter jet dude
so at i don't know two in the morning
and meanwhile all of our phones are it
my phone's the only one on it's at four
percent
so we're calling him facetime anything
trying not he's not he's not waking up
it's at four percent because now you
know time is limited time's limited yeah
so i gotta make a move on a [ __ ]
hotel room on two hotel rooms
this is your second airbnb this is the
second airbnb i've been now locked i've
been now i can't get in i gotta get i
gotta stay in like a holiday in express
or wherever the [ __ ] we landed this was
not in the budget no no no no the second
airbnb the first first if we're being
honest the 5 dollar airbnb wasn't in the
budget either
staying with friends
that was a treat yourself moment uh-huh
little did you know you'd be paying out
the nose every night you were there
so we get locked out we gotta get hotel
rooms everybody
dude he's [ __ ] sound asleep in a
[ __ ] tuna
baby
we wake up now he's he wakes up at like
6 a.m because he went to bed at like 10
30 or whatever you got a full night's
sleep go for a jog
get my day started here he's such an
idiot it's crazy then i wake up with
phone calls and text messages where the
[ __ ] are you guys at i'm worried sick
i'm like take jerk off you locked us all
out of that
i'm worried luckily i have the other
half of that tuna sandwich in the fridge
and you sleep with your apnea mask i'm
fascinated i tried mine again yesterday
just to read with i can't keep it on for
more than a minute really well don't
they
doesn't your insurance
haven't they taken it away from you
they call me up they're like yo you got
to make sure you're using otherwise
you're taking it away oh no yeah
again
what kind of insurance you got
i don't know not norton's guys this
guy's living good i like it
i love it though ah so jealous i mean it
helps you sleep through your friend's
emergencies
so your everything just drips away
because i thought there was an emergency
i was like there was you locked the [ __ ]
out so you did get a hotel yeah we ended
up having to get to hotel and that's
like awkward when you're like on hotels
tonight and i'm like
you're it's past
the night you're checking in
at 2 am yeah yeah it's never
it's never like it no it's just a
vacation but i bet they didn't say a
[ __ ] word did they there's no ring
phones over there do whatever you want
in that hotel sure i didn't make a hot
pocket in the lobby so things were all
right
there is something nice about a hotel i
feel like they're great once you put
that do not disturb sign on the doorknob
oh
that's yours for the stage for the
duration i've never sweet i've stayed at
you know like maybe like a hyatt or like
a jw marriott but you stayed at the ritz
huh i have yeah yeah it's very expensive
i don't do it often and it's only if i
get a hotel buyout and i have to pay a
little extra to get it yeah yeah but i
won't go let me tell you what the best
part of this entire
radio deal has been and there hasn't
been a lot but the best part
entire radio deal has been the fact that
jim
likes to travel in comfort and for some
reason they think that it would be uh
not the greatest thing for morale to put
jim in the hotel that he needs to be in
and me and the cheapskate hotel so i you
get leveled up oh yeah nice i get to
travel in comfort and the hotel that
they put us in in los angeles there you
go i mean my
god is it like i don't want to go home
yeah when i'm there it's the only it's
the only hotel i've ever taken a bath in
what i never use hotel tubs but i looked
at this and i said you know what wow you
should do that at the overlook
i said i said i'm sure that it's not the
cleanest thing in the world but the
people that have stayed here yeah this
is not the same caliber human being that
takes a bath at most hotels
yeah yeah yeah it is you're in their
bubble baths you got your wwe guys
fighting each other
[Music]
yeah i mean it is i got leveled up from
opie and anthony because those guys
traveled first so i got it in the
contract that's the way it is and you
never once it's in there you never let
it go they don't take it out and like
any entertainment stuff like if you
network flies you it's just standard
like yeah yeah they have to do it yeah
part everyone gets it's not even that's
awesome so whenever you guys fly as a
part of the show from it's first class
sirius flies this first class or
business whatever this you know yeah
whatever is available which yeah i
didn't get until i uh i i hitched my
wagon to the gym oh jimmy norton but
yeah yeah first year
and then it's in the oh yeah i'm gonna
leave a week before the show
don't worry sam will find his way there
yeah he's on the john madden plan
he didn't like the flies that would have
no yeah he hated flying he would take a
bus everywhere that's crazy yeah except
mine was yellow it was not the same as
john madden
[Laughter]
ru garbage is available every monday and
thursday on all streaming platforms as
well as their incredibly successful
youtube channel and
the boys are blowing up on patreon go to
patreon.com
are you garbage
thank you guys thanks guys